six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty we are taking phone calls
it's not always easy to tell that that's
what's going on but it is what we're
doing let's go next to the five seven
five area code five seven five go ahead
hello hello this is Kevin Sayuri yeah we
can hear you Kevin we're not on
speakerphone or Bluetooth are we
no my connections bad that would be a
shame because I always avoid
speakerphone when I'm talking okay oh go
ahead we can hear you all right so
Carnegie Mellon University recently
developed a system that would be able to
prevent gerrymandering without the
involvement of a third party it's
basically one party draws all the
district lines and then the other party
chooses one district to freeze so that
no more changes can be made to it and
then they take turns with each part of
that process and the CMU researcher is
verified to do was share with like a
mathematical bank basis and there isn't
even any advantage to going first giving
you thoughts on like how that works and
if it could be actually implemented if
there would be you know passed by any
states or anything okay so a couple
different parts number one I mean I'm
not familiar with that particular system
but I've heard about a lot of systems
that basically have an algorithm they
have an algorithm in a process and they
try to eliminate what you talked about
the advantage of going first a lot of
these things have first mover advantage
so like you know in chess basically if
you play with white versus black you
play with what you're moving first and
so fundamentally sort of like it's a
different game playing as white than
black is sort of what's considered first
mover advantage exists in business and
in other places if you eliminate that
then the something like the system
you're describing or other systems that
have an algorithm could work really
really well I would be in favor of a
system like that although I don't I
haven't reviewed the one you're talking
about there's not that much see that
there's sort of a the problem with
getting States to agree to this stuff is
that the party and power that would
presumably hold the keys to either
saying yes or no to a new system usually
would be the one that was able or would
be able to redistricting and it's like
never really in their advantage to go
with the nonpartisan system if that
makes sense yeah it's real shame that
nobody ever wants to
like prepare things for the future so
that stuff is actually fair instead of
light right always going for oh right
now it's good for me that's exactly
right and unfortunately that also
relates to why I'm not hugely optimistic
about our elected officials deciding to
change campaign finance because they're
all our elected officials because they
won with the campaign finance system we
have so once they're in there's not that
much of a desire from them to change the
system that got them in you know yep
it's it's really kind of messed up yeah
all right Kevin I'm gonna look into that
system you mentioned from Carnegie
Mellon sounds interesting yeah sure all
right very good appreciate it